what's up it's ricky williams check me
out on the bootleg kev podcast
boo lakehead podcast man uh very excited
about our guest today
we have got the legend heisman trophy
winner
fantasy football god by the way when you
when you bounce back i think it was 2009
yep
oh man i picked you up off waivers he's
going [ __ ] crazy
ricky williams is here welcome man
2009 i remember that year very
specifically because it was the first
year i ever played fantasy and i picked
you up off waivers
and that was that the year that the
wildcat was going crazy it was like
ronnie brown and you were doing
it was a year after and and ronnie got
hurt
so i was having a pretty good year and
then ronnie went down towards the end of
the year and i got a chance to start and
my first start was thursday night
against the panthers
i think three touchdowns that game and
and i ran for over 100 yards and i think
i went
like three straight hundred yard games i
remember yeah
yeah um it's crazy because i remember as
a kid
i was never ever as a as a kid i never
was big into college football
but i remember you because you were like
a
cultural phenom when you were at texas
like you won the heisman trophy and i
specifically remember that sports
illustrated cover
when you went to the nfl was it was you
it was uh you mean
mike dicker yeah yeah i remember like
that just like iconic moment that i
always remember as a kid like
um you you had such a crazy year or a
crazy career but you know with where the
the
nfl has moved when when it comes to
testing we do you feel like you kind of
had to take like
you kind of took a lot of bullets for
everybody when it came to the weed [ __ ]
i mean that's not that wasn't the plan
but i think looking back
um yeah i i did and only because i was
really the first person to tell the
truth about it
um because i mean it was strange when i
started when i got
in trouble for for smoking you know
i wasn't even a real smoker i just it
was just bad timing right there were
dudes on the team that were real smokers
and you know but nobody knew and for me
because i was a
i was one of the top players and because
it was made public
and then when i was put on the spot i
didn't lie about it you know
it became a story and it was funny
what i've realized is it gave people
especially back then this is you know
not now in california back then
it gave people an excuse to to say weed
or to say marijuana or
to give people an excuse to talk about
it so you just started seeing people
having more conversations
of something that was kept you know we
don't talk about this it was tough yeah
yeah
now everybody was talking about it and i
think that's really what's what's helped
is that it just started the conversation
yeah i think um
you know back then we all remember it
was it was it was it
you know weed was in the same
conversation as people who'd be doing
cocaine or like
just the idea of smoking weed and being
leveled a troublemaker
is like crazy you know what i mean did
you find
that because back when you were in the
nfl bro when you first got drafted
concussions weren't a thing i'm sure you
know taking as many shots to get you out
on the field was very normalized
putting you on as many painkillers was
very normalized there wasn't we weren't
as aware of
you know the addictive effects of all
these things and
weed to me is like the anti-inflammatory
that's like
you know for any sport but really for
football
it should be pushed to the players i
mean that that's
that's what i believe from my own
experience of being an nfl player not
just playing myself but also being
around other guys and seeing what
happens to the guys
that you know they live off taking shots
and drinking beer with their vicodin
that's their their pain regimen and we
know what that does to people over
a long period of time or people that are
we used to have to take these uh like
indecent is what they are calling
and we used to have to take them the
night before before practice
yeah because if you didn't take it you
know you went out to practice and you
felt like you were 85 years old
but if you took it's called innocent
innocent it's an insane it's like just a
really strong ibuprofen
and if you and if we took it i mean if
you didn't take it
you feel like 85 if you took you feel
like you're 12 years old was this
something that was
uh is is still around yeah they they i
mean they give it out so
it's it's standard when you get into the
nfl the first time you know about this
medicine yeah
you get the everybody or the toradol
shot right everybody
in the nfl knows about this because it's
a lifesaver and
and that's what that's what was the norm
and for me i remember one day i was
sitting in the training room and i was
seeing guys come in
one by one to get their tour doll shot
and i was thinking
if we're doing this for our whole is
we're having to get shots what is this
going to do to our bodies
and then i kind of took a challenge on
to myself i said i want to see how long
i can go in the season
without without having to do that and
and i started smoking a little bit and i
was in the drug program so i had to like
measure it out you know i could take two
hits
the night you know the day after i got
tested and still be fine
and so i found that that worked i did a
little extra stretching
um you know just was more in touch with
my body and i didn't have to take those
those medicines
so i i've learned from myself that
cannabis was better for me than
how long did you did you go the whole
year without having to take one of those
i had to take i had to take one
the second to last game of the season
but that was it what year was that this
was 2000 and uh
this this 2003 when i led the nfl in
cary's i carried them almost 400 times
that's crazy man
it's crazy when you look at your stats
right and and i believe you're like
around top 30 in rushing like
to think like you what your stats would
have been
had none of this [ __ ] happened had
you not had to have gone and played in
canada for a year
like you know like it's crazy because in
09 we're talking about 09
like people counted you out by then
yeah especially in running back years
yeah yeah and it's like this guy bounced
back and
do you ever do you ever have any regret
about how things
played out you know the the main thing
for me
i think reason i don't have any regrets
is because i got over the 10 000 yard
mark that was something that was
important for me
to to say okay that my time playing
football on the field in the nfl wasn't
wasted because i accomplished something
it was productive and yeah and and i did
it in 11 seasons and one of those
seasons only lasted a quarter because i
tore my pec
so essentially i almost averaged a
thousand yards a season
and considering i didn't start for half
my career and considering i was out for
a year then back in and out for
a year then back in then out for a year
and back in
that i feel like i did it and i did it
my way and so i
i don't have any regrets when you got
drafted to the saints
what that that season who was the
quarterback is jake dalome and
well yeah wow jake dolan came on where
did he like that he was like he was a
third string guy
yeah and he just kicked before we we
knew him with the panthers he went to
the super bowl exactly he can't he came
in
against the cowboys and beat a playoff
ball and cowboys team and that was
really kind of his coming out party that
year
who were you hoping to get drafted to
the browns the browns this is
this is like the that was was that the
first year the browns were back that's
for sure they were back and they would
they take tim couch
i took tim couch how'd that [ __ ]
happen so exactly so the first thing is
is i wanted to be the first player
because i thought i deserved it
two you were the best player in the
draft and two going yeah yeah and two i
felt like just who i was and the way i
played the game it just fit well
cleveland cleveland like it's a grimy
town like they would appreciate
exactly like jim brown was there exactly
exactly
that that was what i was hoping for it
didn't work out and then my next
my next was uh indy because i thought it
would have been cool to play with
uh with peyton yeah no no my next was
fit was uh was philly
and because i was the quarterback of
philly it wasn't mcnabb was it that's
who they drafted
oh so it was that year so they drafted
mcnabb this year i was
it was he was number two that year so
that was my second choice because andy
reid
i just love the west coast offense uh i
think i'm the type
and it seems like you were right he's
been onto something yeah exactly
exactly i love that offense and then
third was um indy
played with payton and i i got skipped
past all those and ended up in new
orleans
we don't remember because if there's a
lot of recent football fans who
who think the saints are this perennial
powerhouse
i know and when i was a kid they were
the worst
it was i always thought of the saints
and the bucks as the shittiest teams
when i was a little kid
this is before the bucks had like like
you know early 90s mid 90s bucks were
not good before tony dungy got there
yeah i always just stop the bucks and
the [ __ ] saints
like trash so you go to the saints
mike ditka was he like he seems like
i've seen some of his interviews of
like recently he seems like um
not the best like funnest guy to play
with or play for rather
how how was your guys's dynamic because
so he he that seems like an
act but but it's it's exactly the
opposite
you know because there there are some
coaches who never played
no and so i think sometimes they they
treat us like we're
uh on a matting game or we're chess
pieces but
the coaches that played you know he's a
real football guy yeah they've been
there and so
he's a hard ass on the outside but but
he's the
most amazing like coolest coach ever to
play for
because he's he's been there before you
know so he relates
yeah so you know our first preseason
game my um
my rookie year we played in miami and we
were in la crosse wisconsin
for our training camp and so we played
in miami then we flew back
and curfew was at two o'clock but we we
got in at like one and so we only had
like 20 minutes at the bar
so everyone ran to the bar and dick was
in the bar too
and he looked at his watch and he said
curfew has moved back to 4am
[Laughter]
so he he got he he was probably hammered
as well yeah of course of course he was
yeah but that's what i mean he was one
of he was one of us and so the guys
would go to war they go to war for him
yeah it's it's it's like i said it's
interesting to think like when you got
when you went there did it feel like
there was a you always hear about
places have winning cultures like places
have losing cultures you know we here
at new england and and you know
pittsburgh certain
franchises we always here have that
culture where things are expected and
then we hear about
the other the opposite end right philly
right now you know like
the texans right now when you got to new
orleans
did you feel like it was a losing
culture yes it felt like a losing
culture and and i'll tell you and i'll
tell you why
because the winning cultures and i i
think the best example
is where the patriots with tom brady is
because there is a there is a certain
standard
and everyone fit that that it was about
that standard it wasn't about one player
it wasn't about
it was about the standard it's like it's
like they draft players to fit what they
do
not who's best not who's the name
exactly in
in new orleans when i got there they had
we had a lot of really good players
we had a lot of really good athletes and
especially that first year
who's your who was your guys's wide
receivers that year yeah we didn't have
that many good results okay okay
eddie kinnison uh andre hastings no idea
exactly okay fair enough keith pool i
remember him yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so sun devils
so yeah so but we had it we had but
those guys could fly
right so we had athletes but we didn't
have a team right right
when i came in it wasn't like let's
rally around this rookie and maybe we
can get to the playoffs
it was like who does this guy think he
is you know he's got to prove himself
and and that's part of it but but it
just wasn't that
that welcoming environment and but in
converse when i got traded to the
dolphins
they've been to the playoffs like for
the past 12 years
i mean it stopped when i got there but
it was a winning it was a winning
environment and when i got there it was
that feeling of
okay chad chad pennington was still
there when you got there when i it was
it was um jay fiedler jay felix was
right out
it was right no fielder jay philly's a
kicker for the guard
it was right after it was right after
mourinho retired and then they brought
they brought jay in
tell me if i'm wrong what like tell me
what happened with the running back in
football because
it went from being the running back was
the most popular player when i was
growing up
we there's barry sanders and emmitt
smith and you know
uh terrell davis and all these guys were
the guys who you
almost like when you would play madden
you would pick the best running back
team you know what i mean because
and somehow i feel like the nfl has made
running backs very disposable
it's like you know it feels like they're
the last guys to get paid
when it's time when it's time time comes
up for them to get a contract usually
they'll
it's that running back by committee's a
thing now what do you think happened
with the position that
because back then when when you got
drafted it was
they expected you to carry the offense
yeah you know
i think it's a couple of things and you
know my theory is the first thing is i
think the nature of coaches
changed okay i think when you had the
old school like
you know vince lombardi style the coach
like ditka right they would play defense
and run the ball
right very conservative smash mouth
football
and then you started having you know
these intellectual smart
coaches um like the guy at arizona right
and so they start scheming right and
this morning's yeah and it's more fun
to scheme a passing game and throw in
the it's more exciting
right to scheme a passing game and and
throwing the ball around
than it is to scheme a run game and turn
it and then hand the ball out right
that's part of it the other part is
running backs especially the old way
you know we took a pounding and it just
you couldn't depend on a running back
you can't even think of like like when
you said you had the ball carried about
400 times
no it's yeah you can't even think about
it yeah so
so that doesn't last long and also i
think running backs
even though i think it's the most
skilled position because you have to be
able to do a lot of different things
it's pretty easy to get to get running
backs and i think they learn you have to
move them through because you can't just
depend on one guy for too long
especially now with this these fast
offenses
and also i think at receiver you know
receiver has a good game
you know that's 10 an amazing game is 10
you know 10 touches
right you've touched the ball [ __ ]
32. exactly amazing exactly and
sometimes receivers will catch the ball
and go out of bounds and so
you can have a star receiver and pay him
a lot of money and be
feel confident he's going to stay
healthy but at a running back you give
him a lot of money he's taking a pound
you don't know well you did a good job
of of of uh
like i said i feel like some people
might have counted you out and then when
you came back
you were murdering [ __ ] so you did a
good job of like extending your peak i
guess right yeah
nowadays we'll see someone like you know
um
someone like i'm trying to think um
i feel like we you know we we saw it a
little bit with zeke this year
but you'll see somebody who is like
david johnson let's use a guy on the
cardinals right
david johnson i just remember had like
the crazy season he had some injuries
but when he came back it should
i feel like the drop off for running
backs is quick and fast
like why do you think that is now like
what do you notice
because you did a good job of exp i feel
like you came from the days where like
most running backs had like nine
ten-year
you know we think emma smith and and
jerome
yeah now peterson ap now we see
[ __ ] and they're
they're in and out they got three four
years they get a contract and usually
it's like
you always hear the people always
criticize nfl teams when they give the
running back the fat contract yeah
because
like have you not learned yeah yeah yeah
but that's what i'm saying because
running back is such a difficult
position because
you know that if you're carrying the
load every there's a target on you
you're gonna get hit a lot right i think
you know when you're hungry and trying
to get that checked
it's easier once you get paid it's it's
human nature
who reminds you of uh of the way you
used to play now
um uh fournette leonard fournette
hey i was so happy to see him in the
super bowl they really did good too
dirty in jacksonville he looked so good
but it was a wake-up call for him and he
responded he responded
he looked he looked really good i was i
was impressed
yeah yeah yeah i um i i thought because
i
had i you know when you look at the
stats he had his last year with
jacksonville it's like they just kind of
just
nobody wanted to trade for him like i
feel like tom brady's putting together
like
you know like kind of like like pitts
you know or
the patriots used to always take chances
on players yeah and it didn't work out
they just cut them but you know they
brought ultra cinco over there they
brought uh what was the big fat dude who
was on the uh
the redskins that they took the overpaid
lineman dude
he was supposed to limit our defensive
lineman [ __ ]
he was on the redskins the redskins paid
him out and then
i forget his name big ass dude defensive
lineman it was a defensive lineman yeah
i i don't know but um but you know he
must too randy moss right
because people people kind of cast him
aside when he was with the raiders but i
feel like tom brady is kind of doing
that now
in tampa bay yeah it's crazy like
antonio brown i feel like i feel like
he's
picked he's picking it up but i mean i'm
because there's there's nothing like
experience and if you can get people on
the same page
and they have experience it's there's no
there's nothing that can beat that in
the in the league nothing
and it's pr is probably the x factor of
there's probably
like maybe three or four players in the
league that everyone respects
yeah exactly right like well you know
what we got you
you're tom brady we know we know what
we're here to do you know what they're
saying
yo when you um were coming up you
worked with no limit sports yes master p
at the time was the hottest [ __ ] moving
yes i had a little fake no limit chain
when i was 12
like man no limit was insane
for you know for their run and
masterpiece starting a sports agency
was kind of like you know i don't think
i think the only other person who was
doing something similar that was jay
prince when he was doing boxing and
managing floyd mayweather right
because this was before there was roc
nation sports all that how did you link
with master p
outside of being in the same city you
know you're in new orleans we ended up i
mean
i linked up with them when i was in
school in austin still
and and you know what typically what
happens is agents have runners
you know agents usually don't go after
the players they hire someone younger
that can relate to the players and they
create the relationships and then they
introduce you to the agent
and so terry he's doing interrogator
that was his runner yeah i was his
runner
and me and terry were just cool you know
we were just cool
and and you know i just knew he was
connected to no limit sports and like
you said p
was like was was everything everything
everything you know especially me coming
from southern california
going to school in texas and being just
being introduced to that that all that
whole other one oh that
it was real you know uh fat pad mjg jk
yeah it was yeah it was so it was like
you know mind expanding for me
and you know no limit was was it was a
big part of that and so
i had an agent because i was a baseball
player so i had an agent and i just
thought i would keep that agent into
football
but that relationship fell apart and so
i didn't have an
agent and then so all the like the
normal dudes started coming at me
they just felt like grimy and so i
thought about and i said you know i'm at
the top right now
p is at the top like this could be an
amazing like
partnership that really opens up
people's minds to
doing things differently right you don't
always have to go to that to that same
guy that you know
right we can overlap the worlds and so i
i you know i said let's let's do this
and the contract that you that they
negotiated for you
was a was was did it end up like
did you ever regret making that decision
of course of course
of course of course but you know it's
it's not a negative regret it's
that regret like i was young and naive
and i had like these idealistic ideas
about what i wanted to do with my nfl
career
and i don't regret that you know my i
just remember growing up and hearing
people complain about overpaid athletes
and i just didn't i wanted to be
different and so
what i told pea in in leland my agent
is i said here's what i want you know
because i knew you know there's a
there's a uh
every team has a certain amount of money
that they get in order to sign up
it's a rookie salary yeah and so um and
so i knew i was the only i was the only
draft pick that year
and so i said just give me the max of
whatever that rookie salary cap number
is
and then i'll make the minimum and make
everything else be based off incentives
so it was your idea to have everything
incentivized it was it was me and then
and they tried to talk me out of it they
said listen you have all this leverage
and you have an opportunity you know to
be the highest paid rookie ever in the
history of the nfl
and you were like nah and i and i said
it didn't feel right i mean
it didn't feel right yeah i was young i
mean looking back i'm like
what the hell you know but but it just
didn't feel right to me at the time you
know i didn't i didn't want to
it didn't feel right i wanted to earn it
but and then one so what i regret is i
didn't consider
what if i get hurt and i can't play and
then my first preseason game i get a bad
ankle spray and i end up missing
10 games my first two seasons and so
uh that it backfired but you know once i
got healthy
you know i put up numbers where you know
i hit those incidents
what um what when did you sign your
second nfl contract
so i didn't sign my second well
technically i signed my second nfl
contract
i did it because was the first contract
was four years or five eight years
oh seven years with the option seven it
was seven years with the option
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah seven because
now that's not even
or no i mean what's his name my home's
just signed a 10-year deal yeah but
usually for
yeah usually for a rookie they take four
or five five-year deals because at four
years
at four years you're you're unrestricted
free agent but
again eight year deal that's like that
scottie pippen [ __ ] exactly in the last
dance but you know but i was thinking
you know
that that's why we did the the wedding
pic the wedding the wedding right right
right right
we're married you know i was thinking
they're they trained everywhere we got
eight years traded everything for me you
know like let's do this you know i'm not
messing around i'm not trying to be
hopping around from teams let's let's do
this um
and so but when i got traded to miami my
agent lee steinberg
a new agent talked to the office and
said look you know you made this big
trade to get him over here
you know let's at least sort them out
let's at least like switch it around a
little bit so we talked about the
incentives
and then i i balled out that year led
the nfl rushing and was able to
you know get back on track um so that
was
technically my second contract but
really it was just a
an addendum so my first contract last
year is still connected it lasted all
the way until mine too i finally became
a free agent and then i signed with the
davids
that's crazy so with the master p thing
you were around master p
kind of in the peak of no limit right
towards probably towards the
yeah it was about the peak yeah 99 was
the peak yeah um
you're playing football in new orleans
um you had to be around some crazy [ __ ]
i was you know i was you know they so
they were
there their compound all their stuff was
down in baton rouge which was about 60
miles from
from new orleans um but yeah i was down
there and it was
it was crazy it was just so it was just
so dynamic you know
like we i was down there one time and
they assigned this basketball player
from wnba
and she you know she would mess around
on the on the beat machine
and they were just messing around they
went in there and they they recorded
hootie who like
like just just just sitting out like in
the studio like this hanging out and she
just was messing around there like hey
let's go in the studio
and the dudes just showed up they were
in the studio all night and came out
with us
man that was my [ __ ] how about the truth
of the game [ __ ] the true album it was
like that where
it was just people coming together like
talking getting them recordings that's
why they were putting out albums every
two weeks they were so man everybody had
a [ __ ] album
wait so hooty who was help produced by a
wnba player yes
holy sh who what do you know remember i
don't remember her name but i
it's not even that good yeah i mean
that's [ __ ] crazy
so it was live like that and then you
know they go to lsu
um down the road shoot basketball it was
and it felt like a family it really felt
like a family
yes he murdered silk that's they're all
brothers so you know
yeah that's crazy man how long were you
actually like how long was master p
your agent how long did it last
about a year it was about a year and you
realize like ah man
well the agency just started to it
started to fall apart you know i think
and you know kind of my fault because
i think if i had taken their idea of the
contract and become the highest paid
player
that would have looked better for an
agent right no and i think it could have
turned into something more but
we got so much negative publicity and
negative media coverage
that it wasn't the story wasn't you know
rebellious upstart you know
you know pushes back against agents it
was look what these you know look what
happens when you hire a rapper to
represent you
right that's crazy um
when you you mentioned earlier you're a
baseball player
a lot of people don't know you were
drafted by the phillies right yep
and that was because you know our guy in
arizona is one of those guys
you know yeah i'm just afraid i'm afraid
kylo ren's gonna [ __ ] around i want to
play for the oakland a's one day and
then we're [ __ ]
then we got i don't know who but he's
not no i hope not yeah
um but i like being a two uh two sport
athlete like
house like did you ever take getting
back into baseball
serious at any point in time this is a
great question
i did i did so um growing up in san
diego it was big
uh padres fan yeah big tony grimm fan
and i always thought since i was a kid
i'd be a professional by the way i love
tony gwynn because i felt like he looks
like every other guy in the world and he
was just
a [ __ ] hit anyway i always thought
i'd be a professional baseball player
started playing when i was second grade
didn't start playing football until i
was in seventh grade
um but started playing football baseball
was about the same
high school i started to take off in as
far as football but i still had a dream
to play baseball and so
my senior year colleges junior year
colleges were looking at me
major league baseball teams were looking
at me and i told all the colleges
i'm playing i'm playing minor league
baseball i don't care and then i told
all the baseball teams i'm playing
college football i don't care and they
both were like cool
and so i was drafted by the phillies and
i went to texas to play football and so
what i did is in the summers
after uh after school i would
drive my car to to florida to clearwater
where the phillies
i used to live in tampa love me some
clear water yeah yeah yeah
so yeah so we go to clear water and i
would do like i'd get in baseball
shape and then they would send me i
played in north carolina for two years
played in virginia and then i played in
upstate new york for a year
for a summer and i played baseball all
summer and then at the end of the summer
i'd go back and start
a football training camp um
and so when i got uh to the combine nfl
combine after my senior year all the nfl
teams said you gotta choose either
baseball or football and i was much
better at football and so i said okay
i'm gonna give up baseball and then
um after my second year after my second
year in new orleans
first year again i told you i missed 10
games right so i was starting to think
you know
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man we might have to go
play baseball i might have to go play
baseball
until i i rented a i've rented a spot
down in uh
south mission beach in san diego and i i
called up my old baseball coach from
high school and i said
you know can you get me back into
baseball shape and so i called up my old
baseball agent i started like reaching
out to baseball teams
but um but my strength coach
from the saints called me up and
convinced me to come back to play
football so
when you said baseball shape what's the
difference between baseball shape and
football shape
it's about 20 pounds it's about 20
pounds
and it's about 20 pounds of muscle is is
really so i would
um you know i i in college football
you got to lift a lot you lift weights a
lot right so and i'm the kind of person
i lift weights
first time i ever lifted weights when i
was a teenager i had stretch marks the
next morning
so i literally i get swole and so
when i was instant results exactly when
i was when i was in college
you know i would be i'd be swollen i'd
leave to play baseball and i come back
skinny and fast
because you know baseball it's hot first
of all it's hot in the summer
and just throwing the ball all the time
you know the bulking the shoulders and
swinging the bat
uh i would get i'd get down and be in
great shape
when uh when the football season started
that's crazy
that's we think about all the
players who could've like would mention
kylie murray obviously dion sanders bo
jackson
yeah you probably was like i'm gonna be
the next boat jackson out this
[ __ ] that was my idol that was
my that's why i wore 34.
that's crazy to be the next bill jackson
yo you play four years in college
which is something else that nobody does
anymore yeah
um and then you still went on to have a
long career yeah
but by the time you got out of college
like playing that much
i mean at a high level the highest level
like
did you feel like your body was already
kind of beat down a bit
looking back hell yeah but i think in
the time it just was so exciting
and i felt invincible i wasn't even
really thinking about my body like that
you know and you asked about regrets and
and that's one regret i do have
is that and it's it's crazy but i think
i would
i should have done it is i should have
taken a year off you know after
after college after college because and
if i wasn't going anywhere i'd still be
in my early 20s
but i think having a year off to travel
and just you know
get my mind off of something else i
think it would it would have served me
it would serve me well i have to ask
this question because my friend
is a big ucla fan and i told him i was
going to be talking to you
so he said ask him about the time we
beat them
66 to 3 or something like it was
something crazy do you remember this
game it was
it was so i mean it was two years in a
row you know because in college i do the
home and away series
and so we started it was my junior year
we started off ranked like number eight
right eight and we won our first game
and we they were coming in they lost to
uh tennessee and they came in and we
were you know cocky thinking we're gonna
run all over them
i mean they beat the piss out of us it
was one of those games where it just
it was like i felt like i was in a
nightmare i mean
it was like the kate mcdonald show that
dude is i mean that day
and even the next year by the way how
many [ __ ] mcnounds are there
that's like there's mccowns and mcnabb
okay oh yeah yeah but kade mcdown was
that's the best
college quarterback i've ever seen in
person he he tore us
he tore us to pieces it was nasty i mean
it just was like it just kept going
and going who's the best nfl quarterback
you ever played against well you saw him
with your own eyes and you were like
god damn i feel like everyone feels that
way about my homes now like some of
these throws even when he was getting
the [ __ ] kicked out of him
you know planking across the field i
mean that yeah that's just
that yeah yeah that that's the next
level but like when you were playing who
did you see in person that just were
you you you just me bateman and it was
part of it part of it were the throws
but just how you know he'll walk up to
the huddle and whatever the defense is
doing right
he'll just call it out he's doing that
he's doing that he's doing that
okay we're going to do this we're going
to do this and then just go and there's
when he's when he was on and then you
look over and you got [ __ ] j
fielder and you're like [ __ ] we're
[ __ ]
we're [ __ ] boys it's over
we're over here running the [ __ ] wild
cat there is no quarterback on the
[ __ ] field
i mean honestly that's that's the
feeling when peyton manning is on that's
the feeling and there's no there's
nothing
like what are we going to do nothing you
can do we got to injure him yeah
he gets and he gets rid of the ball he
got rid of the ball so fast it was
nothing you could do
man what would happen if they would have
got android and james and you were
[ __ ]
if you and peyton manning were to play
together no i know i i mean
jesus christ it would have been fun it
would have been fun it would have been
insane
when you when you were like um you know
whenever i feel like
uh you're as high caliber of a college
football player
especially your last year right pros
reach out
um when you kind of have a feeling when
you might get drafted places sometimes
players on that team will reach out and
try to connect with you early uh did
anybody
of no notability do that to you when you
were obviously coming out and
to go in the nfl
no i mean you know usually especially if
you're coming out of college usually
it's guys that you played with in
college rather than on a team
and so um the
couple of guys that i knew in the league
they weren't on teams that were
you know that were that would have
drafted that would have drafted me um
so so no but you know i got close with
marshall faulk
because uh he went to san diego state i
grew up in san diego
and he was in college when i was in high
school and so we we kind of bumped into
each other
and he had just been traded from indy to
say
because saint louis had that they had
that pick and i was i had
visited with saint louis and then they
made that
that trade marshal before the draft and
then you could have been playing with
the the greatest exactly show on turf
yeah but in
that style of offense though i just i
really like that
and i think people looked at me because
it texts me ran the eye
more so people just assumed that i was a
i running back but like
i consider myself the outside
conversable exactly i can do everything
and so
i think i got pigeonholed a little bit
and when this when the colts thought
about peyton manning and the shotgun all
the time
single back um it was closer to what
edrin did in miami and so he was a he
was a better fit in their system
who's the craziest guy you've played
with and that could be crazy like this
guy's a good time
or or a crazy like this guy will [ __ ]
take your face off if we're not
gonna do another another give me the
good time guy and then the crazy guy
like you want to have
behind you at the bar when you're about
to get into a fight another uh another
sun devil
um this dude named uh one of my best
friends in the league terrell smith he
played fullback
with me in new orleans and he just was
crazy for i mean
being full back in the nfl you got to be
crazy especially back then when the
fullbacks were a thing especially when
with coach dick i mean in the kind of
offense we're running
and so terrell would i mean he just was
he got to get himself so geeked up that
sometimes you know he'd have to do
push-ups in the middle of the game just
to like calm himself down a little bit
when you say geeked up like the kids
mean
what do you mean by geeked out he would
do it on some i mean he was on some [ __ ]
well was he on there michael irving okay
so no no no
okay okay but but but but they they did
so this was this was back in the day
before ephedra was out
was uh banned and so hydroxy cut
um they had this ripped fuel they had
these and you would take that [ __ ] it
was like taking meth
yes yes yes yes and so t was on that
he was on that just yoked he tried it he
tried to give me something sometime and
we were playing
we were playing uh panthers and it was
in our quarterback through an
interception and i remember which
quarterback was i put him on blast
it was um it was probably aaron brooks
oh aaron brown brooks was he number two
number two yeah he was aaron brown yeah
and
and i was so like he hopped up on this
that i like
i ran i ran to try to you know make the
tackle
full speed and i missed him and i got
back up and i chased him down like 30
yards and i finally made the tackle
it's like that [ __ ] that dk metcalf did
this yes but i was so hopped up i had to
go and i had to go in the in the
in the in the locker room for like 20
minutes just to like calm down i was my
heart was beating so fast
that stuff is dangerous so he would be
on that and that just made it worse
everybody was probably on everybody was
on that yeah yeah
that's so crazy everybody was was like
because i feel like you know we're in an
era where
things have swayed for weed because i
don't they took it out of like
they can't test for it anymore right
they don't suspend players they don't
suspend players anymore
um but
recreationally weed is widely accepted
now
um i think recreationally there's a
bunch of drugs that are
probably not as big as they were but
when you were we always hear about the
90s and
like we watch movies like um
the last boy scout and and you know and
like all these players just [ __ ]
snorting coke and [ __ ] [ __ ] and
doing steroids and like
was that like the like was was the
because you you played through kind of
two errors low-key you know what i'm
saying yes
did you feel the v like was that the
vibe ever like when you got into the
league as far as just like some guys
were just
[ __ ] shooting [ __ ] up in their ass
pause you know what i'm saying and just
like
and you were a pretty [ __ ] big dude
yourself yeah but like was that
something that was more widely like
like it's just going on so i think
you know i got in the league in very
late 1999 it was
at the very end of i think when that was
more widespread i think the heyday of
that was
yeah those dallas cowboy michael urban
days
but but i think you know it's it's a
couple of things one is every team is
is an ecosystem you know every team is
ecosystem
some teams are chill and some teams you
know
they just they have fun right so and
then you usually have a player like
michael irvin
you know who is animated player who's
you know who wants to have a good time
and football is a very stressful job and
if you we all need a way to
find release and so i think we're
intense kind of people and so
yes sometimes football players get
together they can get carried away but
in a healthy sense we all
we got to really we got to release that
stress somehow
let me ask you this out of all the
sports i dj i do night clubs do strip
clubs do all this right
i feel like out of every sport it's
[ __ ] nfl players everywhere
right it's like no matter where i'm
djing it's like yo the car
we got four cardinals over here randomly
the [ __ ] rams are in the building
like what it's not it's not even
football season what are they [ __ ]
doing in scottsdale like what is
happening
yes it's am i tripping so so if you do
the math right
there's more players there's a lot more
players right there's a lot more players
a lot more players there's you know
52 roster and then you know seven or
eight guys and most of those guys we
have no idea what the [ __ ] they look
like
exactly yeah yeah we might recognize
their name from you know right if you
hear the names
i've seen he's got a [ __ ] helmet on
every time i see him exactly but it's
just
it's just a lot of dudes it is a lot you
have a guy you know you have a lot of
guys that play for a year
play for two years on a practice squad
and they're in the nfl
you know or technically they just got
cut and they're just free agent you know
waiting to get picked up
they're in the nfl so yeah that's crazy
um
it's funny what do you you know
what's your involvement in the in the
weed game now because i feel like you
know you're
when we think of athletes and and
celebrities who have um
you know i associate you with being
ricky williams
the hippie who smokes weed yeah and
[ __ ] dudes up on sunday yeah
yeah yeah that's that's me um and and
that's really what i'm working on is
it you know i'm thinking back when i was
a kid and and
you know the the potheads and the and
the jocks and the
athletes the stoners they're all the
same guy they didn't hang out
right now because that's that was the
time we live in and
as i you know matured and grew i you
know i realized that i was a jock and i
was a stoner
and they were separated and so for me it
was work on trying to bring them
together and so i'm launching a brand
um on 420 called the heisman heisman
heisman h-i-g-h-s-m-a-n and it is really
the i mean
bring in sports and cannabis together
and so this is going to be
a like marijuana strain it's going to be
it was going to be a
lifestyle break it's a cannabis
lifestyle okay so it's kind of like
clothing lines these are the
merch exactly they'll even be heisman
houses so uh sports
can uh cause we gotta get you your own
strain bro exactly we're working on it
we're working out right now so
so yeah i'm gonna get you hooked up with
burner over at cookies man i mean
cookies is doing is doing it right
yeah i mean cookies is a great example
of
of gary payton's selling a lot of weed
with them i i saw
a lot of weed that gave me this popping
trying to get my picture on a little bag
a little baggie come on man we'll make
it happen i'll call i will facetime
burner right now after we get off this
um when you move austin's one of my
favorite cities
um i used to do south by southwest out
there every year
i used to throw shows and and do all
that but it was like one of the cities
when i first went there i had no idea
what to expect
and when i got there i just fell in love
it's like its own vibe
it's you know it i always
you know explain to people from where
i'm from it's like mill avenue in tempe
but like times twenty six six uh six six
sixth street it's [ __ ] crazy
um but it's a liberal city in a red
state was it always like was it always
kind of that like where and when you
went there
how did you like austin like how because
you came from san diego which is
its own thing as well people go to san
diego l.a two different vibes yes yes
yes so i had a very similar experience
so i went on my recruiting trip
um to uh to austin and i never really
been out of california so i thought
you know texas i thought there'd be like
tumbleweed
down on the airport and so austin's a
beautiful city so flying in over the
lakes and stuff i was like wow and it
was december and it was 72 degrees i
remember
i landed and i just and i fell in love
probably within the first
two hours i was in austin um and
it was much smaller i think it was about
500 000 right
people and it was really just the
capital and the university and now that
was it
and especially in the summer time there
was nobody there but it was always
liberal
um you know uh willie nelson uh
has a has a statue there and you know
he's an icon in austin so
it was always more more liberal than
especially than dallas and houston
um but you know as it's grown and it's
grown
crazily it's crazy and then joe rogan
just moved i mean he's [ __ ]
everybody's moving there
yeah there's no state taxes i mean that
yeah yeah me and freddie gibbs were out
there
like two weeks ago for a few days and we
were going to comedy shows and it was
just like
it was it's crazy though the homeless
[ __ ] downtown
kind of looks like parts of l.a it's
getting bad in austin right now it is
man i was like what the [ __ ] i haven't
been since like 2017. i'm like where'd
all these [ __ ] homeless people go
liberal mayors i'm telling you liberal
mayors
yeah it's crazy because like there's a
such thing as being too liberal
yeah because i'm i'm a [ __ ] democrat
i'm not i'm independent but i've always
voted democrat but i was someone who
really liked bernie sanders a lot when
he was running you know
um but there is a such thing as just
[ __ ] being too liberal
yeah and i feel like that's what's
happening here yeah what's happening in
austin it's happening in austin too
yeah because there's that area at the
end of sixth street before there's the
other side of sixth street yeah where
the f where ever there's like
the parking lot with the bridge yeah
like you could and
it's all homeless tents and i was like
oh hell no like we used to walk from one
side there was this thing called fader
it we just walk over that like under
that bridge yeah like all homeless
people i'm telling you also i mean i
i was like dang when i saw like the
homeless people in their tents they're
starting to hang art
they're starting to hate artwork that's
the way it is out here
damn you're in [ __ ] venice you live
in venice yes
i rode my bike through venice last week
and it was the first time i've been
there
in probably two years and i was
blown away by how hor
like the handball court people just
turned them into apartments like
like like you said like you'll walk by
some of these [ __ ] la homeless tents
and they're that better than some of the
apartments that
some of these studios [ __ ] are
writing out here it's covered you know
coveted people abandoned you know people
weren't visiting
venice as much and then the homeless
people just just
i was sitting there and um there was
like five or six tents set up on like a
part of the little hill in front of the
beach in venice
and i was like these [ __ ] have
beachfront property
and they're paying zero dollars now i
don't know where they're taking this
[ __ ] and showering every day that's
different right because that's where
things get a little dicey yes
but i'm like these homeless
[ __ ] wake up every day on the
beach
this is the best this is the best home
like if i was homeless that's what you'd
want to be
if i was homeless exactly that's exactly
where i would be hey
i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we got
to interrupt this for a special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all socks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssocksofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great you know they got all the
licenses spongebob
wwe just everything you could ever want
yeah i mean i'm just throwing socks at
nico blitz right now our producer is
filming this
but uh look go to oddssocksofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving
is they got the naruto and i'm not even
into that [ __ ]
but the socks are fly and the street
fighter socks crazy licenses
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kev
right now save 20 off at checkout do you
like
you know i i've seen some people who
live in venice who are very
specifically with that area because it's
so expensive to live over there
a lot of people have worked their entire
life to be able to afford to live in a
place like venice
beach but now it's like you walk outside
you might step in human [ __ ] yeah
has it kind of like like
made you re-evaluate maybe being over
there is it frustrating
so so when i when i first moved to
venice i was right next to santa monica
and and there's a lot of homeless people
walking around there's for the record
there's always been homeless people
but by venice beach but it's something
else it's yeah it's some other [ __ ]
it's more it used to just be one or two
blocks and now
it's it's it's more but i'm lucky where
i live is is like a little
like gated community right there and so
um i'm good where i live but
i i can see the people that you know
paying you know
almost two million dollars for it i'll
be [ __ ] sick
square foot home and you walk outside
and there's something six-year-old dude
yeah i'll be shooting up and taking a
[ __ ] outside i'd be pissed off oh that's
terrible why'd you leave us like why not
living in san diego
ah the truth is uh there's there's just
more going on up here
that's fair and you know i was i was
talking to a friend today i was driving
up here and
and i was like it's just surreal to me
it's just surreal living
living in l.a cause just like having
this convert you know
walking into us walking into a studio
and someone saying hey i got some weave
it's it's just it's just surreal and
there's some of that in san diego but
it's just
it's not like i go to san diego a lot
and even the weed thing
it doesn't feel like it's like like out
here it's like it's like a culture like
everyone's walking around small
san diego hasn't gotten there yet yes
even though you know it's recreational
you can get the little like
but it's not the same it's definitely
it's a vibe
i love ocean beach though that's my i
like the hippie beach man
i love ocean beach it's my favorite
beach oh that's the spot
on the west coast that's that's one of
the like the unknown spots that that's
because when i was a kid my cousin
worked at uh
sea world he was like a line chef yeah
and i was so poor when i was little we
never could go i never went to any um
theme park in my life we only went there
because he gets free tickets yeah
so uh my aunt had this
ratchet ass apartment uh what was the
name of the street it was it was in the
[ __ ]
trap though my god it was like really
bad
um but then we'd go to ocean beach
every summer for like three years we
would go to ocean beach and they had
this
[ __ ] the dog beach you know i love
dogs and then they got these they had
this place had these big ass slices of
pizza and there's that smoke shop the
black there yes
i used to go buy my [ __ ] black light
posters from there and take them back to
arizona yeah
they had the ill posters at that spot
yeah i [ __ ] love san diego
that's the hippie beach though it is i
feel like you go to the other beaches
it's like you know it's like
it's not a you know i like to be around
everyday people you know what i'm saying
like
especially like la jolla is so updated
it's like yeah
it's crazy do you think um oh as a
obviously
a kid growing up in san diego when the
chargers came to la
like that that had to be heartbreaking
man i can't even imagine
like growing up and that's your team and
then it moves
i mean i'm all messed up because you
know when i when i was a kid the raiders
were in
raiders were in l.a and the rams were in
l.a and and so
san diego we were raider haters you know
we hated the raiders
and we hated la you know even padres
hated the dodgers and so
when the raiders went to oakland you
know we could still not like them but it
wasn't it wasn't the same there's a real
rivalry between san diego and ellis it
wasn't the same
it wasn't the same it wasn't the same
right and then the last straw was when
la chargers like that
yeah i can only imagine it'd be like
arizona we have that same relationship
with l.a
yeah it's like you know it's like beat
[ __ ] the lakers beat the lakers beat the
dodgers
et cetera yeah when i moved out here and
i started to do radio out here and they
told me you might want to start wearing
a dodgers hat i'm like you know what
i can do that because i don't care about
baseball
but i'm not doing that with football or
basketball you'll never see me
and i love lebron yeah you know but i'm
not i can't wear anything because those
lakers on it it's not in my
it's not in my nature man it's it's so
um with the suns you know on uh
you know i played 2k every once in a
while my favorite team
uh which is the oh six sons oh yeah it
was steve nash and quinton richardson
and amari and sean mary
yes yes that's my squad and what's crazy
barbosa yeah it's crazy because like
it's not even like
there's players off that bench that i
don't know why they didn't make them
because the bench
you know what's crazy about those old
ass teams on 2k is that
like 90 of the players on the bench are
just made up players made up players yes
yeah it's like [ __ ] man where's you know
where the [ __ ] is tim thomas on the
bench
you know
what's your in your opinion the best
game you ever played
probably the um probably the game
my actually my um my freshman year in
college
freshman year in college we were playing
texas a m and
back then they had the best defense in
the country and i was a freshman
fullback
and i was scared was i'm right i was
scared and i remember it was like the
first
end of the first quarter they ran a
blitz and we ran a draw play and they
kind of ran themselves out of the play
and i just broke up the sideline
for a touchdown and i was so like so
shocked that i had that i had a nice
play
and i ended up finishing the game with
165 yards and two touchdowns and we
we beat them and won the conference
championship that's great so that just
as a freshman showing up against the
you know putting up a buck 60. yeah wow
what what's what's your what was your
career high in the in in the nfl when it
came to yards
like in the game you know 223 i think
i'm one of only four players to have
back-to-back 200-yard games i think we
had 223 against buffalo then i had 216
the next week against chicago
jesus christ man yeah i was i was i was
on one i was
he was on that [ __ ] hydroxy cut just
[ __ ]
[ __ ] wait wait wait wait what was that
with the dolphins over the dolphins yeah
[ __ ]
defensive players that scared you
um okay if i'm being honest john lynch
a little bit okay safety for the bucks
yep
gm of the 49ers yes yeah exactly um
ray lewis i mean i remember my my rookie
year we we played him i was hurt
but i was i was glad i was hurt that
game because
he just is so smart and so fast and
and and so girthy like when he hits you
i mean he was all over the field and
when he hit you
it hurts so so he was one
he's laughing about girthy he's sick
[ __ ] all right consider you could see i
guess you say girls your
mind always the mind always goes there
who else yeah um
that's it you know um you know there's
the two two
two players both played for the patriots
um
who i had like battles with i wasn't i
wasn't intimidated but they they would
come and hit you
rodney harrison yeah uh and lawyer
malloy
but mainly safety so every uh every
wednesday
when we we would get our scouting report
and the first thing i would do is i'd
look to see how how much the safeties
weighed
that's how i knew what kind of week it
was going to be if they were 210 and
under uh
you're going to destroy them i gotcha i
got them those are the 220 safeties you
know
you got to get your mind right yeah
because what rodney harrison
when you were in that division when did
the patriots win their first super bowl
0-1 0-1 so you
were in the division were you already in
no you you got their 102. i got there no
we played in 01 runs in new orleans but
i got there to miami you know too
yeah when you played him did was was it
brady or bledsoe it was brady
ah that's crazy do you remember like
like at the time that we didn't know
that tom brady was gonna be tom brady it
was 2001
2001 no one knew i think no nobody knew
that might have been the one of the
first games he
said nobody knew and he like he shredded
us because in new orleans we had a
really good defense
he should like we went up there and he
shredded us and so
everyone everyone was taking note but
nobody knew nobody knew what was coming
that's crazy yeah yeah and then you had
to play them every twice a year
after that i used to love playing i
hated playing them and i loved playing
them
i loved it because of the competition
but i hated it because they were always
ready
yeah you know because we always hear
about bill belichick being this
defensive mind
so he had to defend you for however many
years
is it all true was it was it is it the
coaching is it the player
it's mainly the coaching and a lot of it
has to do with scouting for instance
they like how they watch film and their
scouting team right that they had this
note that whenever i adjusted my gloves
it meant it was going to be a running
play so
so every every little cue every little
cue they could find
they give it to the defensive players
and so a lot of times you're playing
patriots and they're calling out to play
before before and was that true
it's true so every time you just some
but but i mean
it wasn't true 100 of the time but not
enough time to work times where yeah
where you get a head start you know and
we ran the ball so much that
it didn't it didn't matter um but but
yeah so
and you know we played them in 2009 2008
the wildcat game
and it was the opposite because they had
never seen the wildcats so they couldn't
prepare for it and they didn't know what
to do they were running into each other
arguing on the sidelines and we it felt
so good to whip them up
yeah when y'all were doing the wildcat
it was you and ronnie brown
and at the time i i don't recall there
being a better one-two punch when you
really because ronnie brown was a
[ __ ] monster
yeah um the cowboys they had mary and
barbara and
barbara and the other guy um i know
you're talking about um
thomas jones thomas was it thomas no
thomas jones felix jones felix
felix jones felix jones and marion
barber yes yeah yeah but
but it but the the wildcat i want to say
you guys are first
at least i'm a pretty big football fan i
don't think i saw anyone do it before
you did well just before we did it
um our offensive coordinator our
quarterbacks coach david lee was at
arkansas and felix jones and uh
miriam uh uh mcfadden yeah yeah
they they ran it in arkansas wow
so when when you guys decided to do it
in the nfl are you thinking like this is
[ __ ] crazy
we're going to get eight up we're this
is i was like this i was like this high
school
high school [ __ ] but then we started
off on two and then we were like okay
we gotta try some [ __ ] we gotta try some
[ __ ] and so we
we we put it in against the patriots
that first game and ronnie had like
you know had a 60-yard had 120 through
for a touchdown i had like almost 100
yards rushing and
and we ended up making the playoffs that
year so it was it really
was that wasn't um brandon marshall
wasn't
wasn't there yet right he came the year
after the did you play with him
i did how was he as a as a dude man
because i think he's one of those
wide receivers who don't get enough
praise for the career he's had because
man i remember when i was
like i had like 20 some odd catches in a
game yeah i mean
you know if you're just standing next to
him he's a
he's he's he's like a lie he's like a
lot a defensive end that's how big he is
and great athlete a great teammate
um and i think i i got him later in his
career where he was starting to figure
it out and kind of mature a little bit
and and we were really close but yeah
when he was on
uh he couldn't he couldn't be stopped
can you reveal who your biggest smoking
buddy was in the nfl
hmm so okay
so here's here's the issue here yeah is
that
um you don't want to snitch well it's
not even that i want to don't want to
snitch
is that for 80 something percent of my
nfl career i was in the nfl's drug
program
and i was the star player for most of
that time and so nobody on the team
would want to be he was trying to smoke
with me yo how did you finesse the drug
because when you're in the nfl drug
program it's their job to try to catch
you up so how did you
get through it as as much as you did
there's this drink
there's this drink and i forgot what it
was called detox
because because everyone knows a weed
takes like two weeks to get out of your
system right
well well it depends on how much you
smoke it depends how much you smoke it
depends how much body fat it depends how
active you are
and so i got it down to a science where
eventually i realized
so at one point i was being tested nine
times a month okay so that's [ __ ]
yeah so that's like two that's two times
a week and so what i realized
they they never tested me on
back-to-back days so if dude would call
me up and he tested me
in the morning before i went to work six
am i pee in the cup you know i had a
good day because i knew that when i got
home i could smoke that night
and i could take i could smoke um
probably five hits and be good for like
three days
okay because i wasn't it wasn't stacking
it wasn't building up in my system it
would
it would go in then it would go out um
and then
later i realized you know i got to the
point where i could take two hits
the day before a test and still pass the
test and so i just had to like ration i
just had to ration it out
but earlier in my career when i was just
smoking i just would drink a drink
and get it at the head shop and you
the guy will call me and say i'll be
there at six o'clock in the morning so i
set my alarm for five
i get up i drink to drink wait 15
minutes drink water
15 minutes drink water pee one time and
then your urine is clean for five hours
and that worked i mean i used to have
like in my closet i just had like
like probably 20 bucks [ __ ] time all
that [ __ ]
yes cases i buy them out every time i
win you ever use anyone else's pee
because in the nfl they probably watch
you piss to your knees
you know pants to your knees that's
crazy
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah oh man
but you know but i will say i will say
um later in my career
the drug dude the test dude it was the
same guy and we became really cool
and so then sometimes i you know i tell
my wife to pee
to pee and put in the bathroom and then
when i go in there but
but yeah do you recall the highest
you've ever been in your life
and it could be on anything mushrooms i
don't know whatever
i don't know do you recall like just the
the most out of your mind you've ever
been
i don't know i mean i had a rough week
last week i ate mushrooms ate an edible
smoked my face off and got [ __ ] okay i
do in austin
i do this was in austin yes i do i do
remember i do remember a time
and it was like it was mixing stuff it
was mixed it was when i was in new
orleans
yeah i was young i think i was smoking i
was drinking
x probably something else i don't even
remember but yeah i was
i was gone i remember i was still gone
uh
uh i was telling my friends i had to be
some good accuracy if it was in the 90s
yeah that was what actually was real it
was yeah early early two days
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah i just remember
i was i was gone in new orleans and
where i thought i was in one part of
the town but i was in a completely
different part of town
i don't even remember showing up at the
[ __ ] magnolia project
all i know is that i got dropped off at
my house by a by a sheriff
okay here's all i remember i got dropped
off by the sheriff
and he called me the next morning to
cooperate our stories to make sure that
i was good
wow so he could he could have arrested
you oh i'm guessing
because he looked out for me he's like
you're the [ __ ] you're ricky williams
man we we got a game
i was i was close friends with his boss
and and thank god
wow when you were in new orleans
it was like the beginning of cash money
it was the beginning
it was like no limit was kind of you
know and cash money was like
this yes it was yeah okay i remember i
was in new york
i was in new york uh for the heisman
stuff in the club
and they just started playing that um
juvenile high
juvenile yes yes they just started they
put they put jay-z on the remix and [ __ ]
yeah yeah i just started playing it i
was in a club of new york i i remember
yeah yeah so like did did you end up you
know
we always see the young rapper dudes
always have relationships with the big
superstars in the city did you ever
end up i mean there was kind of a weird
there was a weird rivalry between no
limit and council
kind of in the middle but okay okay but
earlier early when i was there
um my first year there i was at a club
and juvenile was there and we you know
we said what's up and then
towards the very end um when hot boys
were getting really big then i
you know i hung out with them a lot more
your time in miami
uh early early 2000s miami was
[ __ ] trick daddy and oh slippery
slide records yeah
yeah yeah trina yeah i mean how was how
what was it like being in miami in the
early 2000s and and
and having your best professional you
had your best year there yeah it was it
was i mean it was
it wasn't the same kind of rivalry but
but you know
patrick and trina like they were tight
with edrin you know
he's from there exactly exactly so it
wasn't and everyone kind of compared you
guys
yeah so but i i mean i love it right
we're tight
but it was just kind of that but i mean
whenever i saw him it was it was cool
he's a florida boy for real yes yes
exactly but um
but it was yeah it was awesome it was
awesome being a miami at that time
you know south beach was was was popping
i mean like
how much [ __ ] were you getting at the
time in life like you i mean listen
you're in miami i mean
by the way your college had to be crazy
college college was crazy i'm more of a
uh quality quality over quantity
i i love a quantity of quality quantity
of qual
what's the highest amount of quantity of
quality you've had at once
uh at once just three but in like a day
before something
seven so you had three girls and you
three and me yeah
oh so one time but but in a day probably
seven
so in in miami yeah because it might i
it's
miami is just it's just such a sexy city
like
every time i go down there i can't help
it i just love going to tootsies man i
mean
i love tootsies i bet you he's like i
ran in and out of that place
vip is 400 bucks anyway um
wait wait what's it wait wait how would
you hand your foursome
that's kind of that's a moment in life
this was right out of right out of um
right out of college so this is when i
was in i was single i was in new orleans
a rookie i had a big-ass house just
running it up
yeah we yeah you know i mean i don't
want to like
you know seven in a day too that's
impressive
yes you know that's just being done
hydraulically that's just being dumb and
flexing your muscle you know
the camera you had to be on seven girls
in a day you gotta be on something you
gotta be on some hydroxycut or some of
that [ __ ] you were talking about that
your fullback was on
did this that's impressive at the most
i did two in a day you know in my heyday
seven is you know but that's like what
groupies why when there's
people that that are called groupies
it's easy it's easy
right right it's easy it's harder to say
no
at some points than it is to say yes
back then
you know nowadays it's very popular to
have a to be a beautiful woman
and like you said there's more nfl
players than anybody
but most beautiful women that i've ever
met some sort of nfl player
slides in the dms right um
and it's funny he's laughing
in your day um
we didn't have social media so like
obviously there's clubs would it
literally be [ __ ] in the hotels
though like just trying to get chose no
because like
on the hotel in the hotels they have we
have security okay okay we have a crew
you're outside the elevator
and so it's it's more like they just
know the
bars or the clubs or whatever that the
players hang out at
that's that's really how it did you ever
have or like if we do like charity
events or something
they might you know they might show up
you were a celebrity um
at the time culturally not just if
you're a sports fan
um did you ever get any sort of
attention from any celebrity females
i didn't i mean i i don't think so
i had i had fantasies you know
i think everyone in my you know halle
berry
you know let me ask you something
you see monsters ball yeah and so i
remember the first time i saw halle
berry's tits was in swordfish with john
travolta
yeah i saw that [ __ ] at metro center
mall and as soon as it came out on dvd i
just paused it it was a vhs
i was like i was like look at those
and then monsters ball billy bob
thornton just kind of did a sting man
yeah is halle berry like the it for you
like when you were growing up
she was yeah she was she was she was the
hit one yeah halle berry in the 90s was
the one
yeah was how halle berry was the last
boy scout we talked about that movie
ever wasn't she in there
that was a crazy movie and the [ __ ]
the running backs running he pulls
the gun out and just starts shooting
players on the field
[ __ ] crazy damon wayans yeah that
what's your what do you think is the
best football movie ever made
there's some good ones um
or your favorite i like i like any given
sunday any given sunday was good
i mean because i was i think i was in
miami i was in miami at the time and so
um i got that's when i got really close
with jim brown when he was there and
uh shooting and shooting that movie but
uh
i just i think it it wasn't 100 accurate
but it was the closest
it was the closest yeah like i know we
got guys like that on the team yeah
exactly who was like the superstar guy
that you were like
you know like like who was like the most
diva guy no one's
diva is probably a negative word to use
but when we think of like
the prime times or the you know michael
joe horn joe horn i mean his nickname
was hollywood
hollywood hollywood that's so he was on
that [ __ ] he was on that wide receiver
[ __ ]
it was a it's a good story because you
know he
he got picked up by the by the chiefs
played a little bit
and then as a free agent he came to new
orleans and no one knew who he was
he bought he balled out and so he was
always hollywood but
but he you know he earned it he earned
it he you know
the one where he had the cell phone he
had the cell phone
yeah he did that in a celebration right
yeah yeah he had a cell phone in the
in the goal post and he came pulled it
out actually it's crazy
would you ever get into coaching or
anything now ah
i i have so if the right situation came
i
i coached some college kids in china it
was cool
yeah i know just chinese football
players there are when i got there there
wasn't
but now there are so we coach these kids
are you saying that you're responsible
for chinese football i am i respect that
yeah okay
i have a lot to do with it that's
beautiful and so you know it was a job
where i got to travel
and it was like two weeks two weeks
and then take him to sweden to play in a
tournament and then i coached
some kids in tijuana i like
international coaching because
you can you make a bigger effect on the
kids and because you're teaching them
right an american game and it's it's
you know less time consuming and it's
fun it's fun because you're like it's
almost like
these kids aren't uh you know we come in
a a culture of entitlement now
you know even with athletes right and
and to be able to i'm sure teach someone
a new sport that you're so passionate
about it kind of
brings it back to why you did it in the
first place exactly and and they're
they're college kids and so like they're
and they're chinese so they're super
smart and teaching them are you trying
to say all chinese people
i mean it's it just means that they
value you know
they value right they value intelligence
and so
where and so they were coming as these
intellectuals trying to learn this game
of football and they learned the game
like this like i could install
i could put in nfl type stuff and they
could pick it up wow the hard part was
when
we got him on the field and i had to
teach him the defensive guys when the
ball snapped
you have to go that way you know because
the linebackers when the ball snap they
start back pedaling
right so i just that that the idea of
the game where you have to be aggressive
and you have to go attack
that took a little bit of time to try to
teach him but with the x's and o's
they picked it up quick why did you
never get into uh because i feel like
you got a great personality and i feel
like like i said culturally you're
[ __ ] huge
um there's some really shitty dudes
doing football commentary and getting
paid handsomely for it that used to play
football they were never that good
like i don't know how the [ __ ] matt
hasselback's brother talks about being a
quarterback tim hasselbeck
this [ __ ] was horrible trendover
was [ __ ] up
anyway they sat in a lot of meetings so
they right they know what to do but
did did you ever think of taking that
career i did uh and i dabbled in it a
little bit
uh for the past seven years i've been
doing some stuff for texas i i do the
pre-game show and a postcard oh nice
so i did a little bit and i even got
invited up to bristol and to do some
stuff at espn
but it's too much you know you sit there
all day
you live in l.a man sports center's
right here you could it's too much like
all the study and
like it's too much i like to come in and
coach and teach what i know but having
to watch film and talk about what
everyone's doing like
it's just too it's too much to to be
prepared to do a good job so
i decided what are your thoughts uh
currently on texas and uh and it's
football program and you know i think
you know obviously the football
program's seen better days you know yeah
i mean
we've struggled the past couple years
have been a little bit better
um we just hired uh sarc you know who
was at sc and i think
uh a great offense of mine i think you
know
going through um struggling with
alcoholism and
humbled him yeah and so and they spent
some time with coach saban so i'm
excited
i'm excited i think i think he's ready
to to shine
and texas is ready to get back on top so
we got a great running back from
actually from arizona how nice yeah
um jean robinson uh he was a freshman
last year he was amazing
so yeah we got we're off to a good start
are you the greatest texas longhorn
football player of all time
i have the most records i suppose it's
it's got to be you
and the only other name i can think of
is vince young earl campbell or
yeah earl campbell [ __ ] yes yeah so i
think it's different i think you know
you played four years too yeah vince i
think if vince would have played another
year he definitely would be
he'd be the best but but even when he
did what he did in the rose bowl
oh the rose bowl was legendary that's
that's gonna that's gonna go down as the
best performance by a college football
player ever
that was legend and that and that's
almost like i always look at that game
as like when lebron beat the warriors
yes because you usc back then was like
the dream team they had glendale white
and reggie bush
and matt leinart it was like two heisman
trophy winners what the [ __ ] is going on
here
yeah it's great by the way linda white's
a wild dude met him in person crazy guy
um yeah i think
when we think of college football vince
young coming to the nfl
he run rookie of the year and then man i
feel like the nfl i feel like
jeff fisher did him dirty you mentioned
it earlier about about running backs
and longevity so much running backs any
position
but quarterbacks running backs is fit
it's
just do you have a good fit with the
system do you have a goal with the head
coach
if you if there's a good fit you can
play for it yeah i feel like vince young
could have maybe went to anywhere okay i
feel like jeff fisher was was hard on
him man like so the story
is that the owner the owner from houston
and that's where um that's where vy's
from
wanted said we're drafting him and and
coach fisher was like no
i don't want him they bumped heads and
so he kind of held that against vince
the whole his whole career which is
trash
this is trash to me like young players
in the nfl
college player college kids coaches have
such a
pivotal role in their lives and and i've
seen coaches ruin
ruin young men who do you think
right now is an example of that that you
feel like is like [ __ ]
you're just in the wrong place
hmm um
it's a good question it's probably a
quarterback i would say sam darnold
would be the first person that comes to
mind just
because he's probably had some of the
worst coaching i don't know that adam
gase is [ __ ] horrible
adam gates is is bad is is bad yeah
i think um
drew luck drew luck yeah okay
i think drew luck i mean i saw him
playing cop he was great in college
i saw him playing college he's got an
arm he's got so much talent it's just
him finding finding the right coach in
the right system
because he seems like the kind of the
kind of player who really will
put the work in will study yeah
yeah and even you know i think that that
the cardinals are a perfect example of
why the coach matters it's like oh they
literally like
they hired that guy and they're like yo
you need your
like you know it's a fit thing it's like
it's everything i'm telling you
if you look you look at um you look at
belichick and brady i mean that that's
the
that's the best example and i think you
know when when brady went to tampa
early in the year what did you notice
yeah it was kind of dicey it was kind of
dicey right
bruce aryan don't give a [ __ ] he'll say
some [ __ ] in a press conference
got everyone talking like are they
beefing
what the [ __ ] is going on in tampa but
they got on the same
page and i think that's probably the
most talented offensive team peyton
manning's ever had you could say west
welcome randy moss but like
top to bottom
and then his running backs are crazy two
of them two of them are crazy
and lashawn mccoy is like the third guy
yeah exactly yeah it's it's it's wild
well look i appreciate you for coming
through anything else you want to
promote while you're here man
um to my podcast so i just i just
started a podcast oh [ __ ]
uh it's called curious questions with
ricky williams and
um one of the things i got into like in
the middle of my career was astrology
and so i do i bring people on i look at
their astrology chart and then we i just
ask them questions based off of what i
see
so astrology uh when you say it's
because i'm not an astrology guy so
you got to help educate me this is kind
of like a
this is not like like your scorpio yeah
yeah it's that yeah so
i'm gonna okay so i lean on the
belief that i don't i don't i don't know
about that [ __ ] is what i'm saying yes
i don't know if it's [ __ ] i mean
people say oh you're an aquarius this
means
i'm like does it yeah how do you know
but with that being said
give me a like a breakdown of astrology
and why you're so passionate about it
it's a very interesting thing to be
passionate about
yeah so um so when i when i retired in
2004 i just left
everything yeah and i right before i
retired i realized that everything in my
life had been built on
me being a football player and i gave
all that up and so i was kind of i was
lost and i met this lady
and she heard i was a football player
and so she got curious about my
astrology and so i gave her my
information and she looked at the chart
and it's just strange lady i i didn't
even i just met
and she looked at my chart and we had
this conversation and based off my chart
i've
i
just felt like this woman knows me
better than my closest friends
right right and so i just got really
curious and it just gave me a lot of
clarity and direction in a time where i
was lost and so i got curious and just
started studying it
and the more i studied i just started to
notice wow there's just some crazy like
crazy connections going on
and the more i studied i just started to
notice more crazy connections
and and then i just started talking to
people about their charts and people
got something out of it and so i just
kept doing it so your podcast you look
at people's charts
and based on that you can kind of
hit them with some questions some
interesting questions wow
yeah so an example in and i don't like
there's a whole chart it's not just
you know being an aquarius there's a
whole bunch of other stuff going on
but like if in general right if i was at
an aquarius on
uh i would talk about that you know for
aquarius a lot of it has to do with
with learning to to not care what other
people think okay
i've mastered that yeah exactly and so i
would i would ask i would ask questions
about stories
because i want the listeners because
when someone says they're an aquarius it
doesn't really describe you it describes
it describes the the the dramas that
you're going to experience in life in
the
dramas that aquarians experience what's
the drama of being an outsider
okay and learning how to be comfortable
thinking for yourself
that whole process and how it looks for
everyone is going to be different
that's interesting like a lot of times
within aquarius and probably 80
of them this works because aquarius is
about questioning authority
and so typically right query one of the
one of the
one of the parents one of the parents
you know
has a difficult time with the with the
aquarium yeah yeah i know that's
i question authority my whole life yeah
yeah i'm always butting heads with
bosses
what the [ __ ] did this [ __ ] got
us doing over here yeah
yeah like what the hell yes yeah
when you when you left football for
those years um
it was a it was everyone was surprised
cut off like you know
you were what like five years six years
in the league six
five five years in um and you leave
football
you know i think a lot of people the
perception was you turned into like this
hippie guy right
i did right so you turned into this
hippie guy
um you learned about aquarius and
exactly astrology
uh did was there anything else spiritual
that you went through during that time
that that helped shape you
yoga yoga meditation holistic healing
like all of that all of it came in that
time in that time period
and it surprised me i didn't know i was
a hippie until i
just i ended up in this town in
australia called byron bay and i just
felt
you ended up there i just i mean so it's
kind of it's kind of funny
i mean it's kind of funny where i ended
up in australia i had this
i had a friend who right after i retired
she said she was traveling to samoa
right so i was like
[ __ ] i don't have nothing to do let me
go with you and so we went to samoa and
then we went to fiji
and then she started tripping so i was
like bye and like tripping on
on hallucinations just freaking out on
youtube acting like yeah you know
anyways and so i was like you know i
don't need this
and i was like okay what am i gonna do
now i'm in the middle of the pacific you
know and then i
and then i was like oh [ __ ] australia is
like really close and i want to go back
there because
i had a good time and so i flew back to
sydney hung out in sydney for a couple
of days and then i
i got this idea of this town called
byron bay that i always wanted to go to
and i'd never really been on a greyhound
except from san diego to el centro
and so i and in australia the greyhound
is like
everybody travels in the greyhound so i
took a greyhound from sydney to this
town in
uh byron bay and i thought i'd be there
for a couple of days because i wanted to
photograph a
lighthouse that was there and end up
staying there for a couple of months
and i and i learned there that i was
that i was a hippie
and then from there on i came back and
started doing hippie stuff i became a
vegetarian
started doing yoga stuff are you still
vegetarians no not anymore
you gotta eat meat man after i retired i
moved back to texas and it was
it's too hard yeah yeah with that
barbecue
some of that barbecue in texas man i had
some pork belly
that was like life-changing a couple
weeks ago i was like why can't they make
it like that in california yeah it's
just
it's just that so now you're not you're
back to eating meat
yes um we always mike tyson always
describes
um how he found like dmt
yeah did you ever get into any of the
hallucinogenic
side of things ayahuasca yeah so
ayahuasca is something
you do you did ayahuasca yeah me too
yeah i really want to do it yeah
it's an experience i hear you gotta have
a shaman and like it's helpful i think
it's better if you have a shaman and i
say do it at least
how many times have you done it i've
done it seven times i say
do it at least at least four times
because the first time a lot of times
it's
just getting your bearings but you got
to do it a couple times to really
did you um do it like did you go to
costa rica or
where were you at i did it um i did in
southern california this
there's a shaman from hawaii that
he would come here every year for six
months and he would do
pretty much every every weekend he would
do friday saturday wow um
and so i did it with him a couple of
times i have another friend in topanga
uh who has ceremonies at his house and
did it a couple times but i would love
to go to
the amazon and do it i heard it's
hardcore there but but i want to
want to have that experience they you
know i had a friend of mine who did it
who
was addicted to cocaine and uh you know
had a
issue with you know sleeping with every
woman he met and
gambled like a crazy person and he did
two days straight
and it like changed his life he said it
was like doing 30 years of therapy it
shows you stuff
but the truth is you have to be ready to
you have to be ready you got to want to
see that you got to be ready to see it
but
it shows you stuff yeah what's do you
remember the craziest thing uh that you
got out of it or that you saw while you
were
while you were on eyewash because i i'm
really curious into trying it
so for me you know i'm more kinesthetic
so it was more the feeling of it and
when you drink the drink like the
experience was you can feel like going
into your stomach and like pulling
like stuff out of your body and then
most people
purge and so when you go to ayahuasca
you know you sit down
in your spot and they give you like a
bucket
they call it purging because it's not
really puking because you're not
supposed to eat
you're not supposed to eat that going
into it yeah and so it's really
it's stuff like it's coming out of your
mouth it's coming out of your eyes
sometimes coming out of your ears did
you
did that happen to you yeah wow yeah um
and and i you know i had like i don't
know if it was
past life stuff but i had you know
images of being like a
native american um a native american
warrior
and and having to choose between um
going to war and and going to train with
the shaman
you know um and that's kind of that's
kind of how my life
has kind of been you know where i did
the warrior football player thing
now i'm kind of moving towards the the
shaman
yeah someone uh my friend said he felt
he he said there was a lady
like a voice her whatever he was saying
right
yeah and he was like um he was like
there was like trauma that i had as a
child i don't even remember
but it was it was holding me down
without me even knowing it and he was
like it was almost like
they committed surgery on me yeah and
they cut it out of me yeah
yeah that shit's crazy did you hear like
a lady or like because i
i've heard that multiple times from
people that there's like
you know some something that's talking
to you talking you through it or like
so yeah so i haven't heard a lady but
but
you know for me it's an ayahuasca um an
animal
will come i think a wolf came one time
uh
in a a a white rhino came another time
wow um but you know it's it's kind of
that same
state that you experience when you
daydream or even sometimes a night dream
yeah yeah you know
that's yeah and it shows you it shows
you stuff
it has did it change you it did it did
you know
but i've been doing this work for a long
time like meditation like doing a lot of
retreats you ain't new to this
i'm not yeah exactly it ain't on
yourself so when it comes up it's like
okay
okay okay this is this is what's next
this is what i'm moving through
right right right right that's [ __ ]
wild man you got to do it man i know i
know i need to
one of my friends has someone in malibu
that does it yeah but i definitely i
want to do it like
so make sure i'm with the right person i
mean the group the group you deal with
is is extremely important
yeah yeah that's wild well look thank
you for coming through of course
uh your podcast how many episodes have
you done um
number five is is releasing number five
tomorrow
who who's it with um bethany
cassantino she's um singer part of about
best coast
oh okay for sure well um check out the
podcast it's called curious questions
ricky williams drinking williams yeah
you got to get you got to go to austin
and get rogan man
yeah i mean i mean we reached out to him
so we're working on it i mean he's got i
mean listen if he wants to tap it with
the king of austin he's got to hit you
up man exactly
they got put your statue next to vince
young statue and then
you know you know i mean i say austin is
the only
the only town in america that has
statues of two potheads me and willie
nelson
mm-hmm willie nelson do you ever smoke
with willie i have
fire yeah you ever smoke with snoop i
have
me too i've only done snoop oh wait and
have you ever met wiz
uh i haven't met wiz we'll make that
happen please
yeah yeah he's a legend the only yeah i
think i've hit all the bucket list
rappers
i just haven't smoked with um with like
willie nelson or i smoke with one of the
marley brothers which is cool
oh wow i haven't even done that or one
of one of his sons uh steven marley
i smoke with him in boise
yeah they had this big ass like monster
jar on the bus of just [ __ ]
just the craziest weed and it was like
you got a bob marley tattoo right yeah
right
yeah yeah yeah and it was like okay i
smoked with a marley man i'm chilling
crazy by the way rest in peace the bunny
whaler that's how we're going to end the
podcast ricky williams man
go check his podcast out thanks for your
time brother thanks for having me